This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. The second annual Women's March was held in January. The focus was on getting people registered to vote. Everyone who enjoys the privilege of voting in our elections must do with the House of 2018. Let's get more people in Washington on our side, right? It drives me into the voting booth. In the upcoming 2018 midterm elections, there are going to be many women running for political
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。第二届女性大游行于1月举行。重点是让人们登记投票。每一个在我们的选举中享有投票特权的人，都必须在2018年众议院选举时行使这一权利。让我们让更多支持我们的人进入华盛顿，对吧？这驱使我走进投票亭。在即将到来的2018年中期选举中，将有许多女性竞选政治
office. According to research from Rutgers University, more than 400 women are estimated to be on the ballot for the US House of Representatives. That's unprecedented. All this made us want to revisit an episode we first aired in October of 2016. If you look at the gender makeup of Congress, you'll see that fewer than one in five legislators are women. At Fortune 500 companies, fewer than one in twenty CEOs are women. And look at all the presidents of the United States. Now, I know there was a long time when women couldn't be president, but if men and women had an equal shot at the White House, the odds of having 45 presidents
职位。根据罗格斯大学的研究，预计将有400多名女性竞选美国众议院议席。这在历史上是空前的。所有这一切让我们想要重温我们在2016年10月首次播出的一集。如果你看看国会的性别构成，你会发现议员中女性不到五分之一。在财富500强企业中，女性CEO不到二十分之一。再看看历任美国总统。现在，我知道过去很长一段时间女性不能当总统，但如果男人和女人有平等的机会入主白宫，连续45位总统
in a row all be men, about 1 in 36 trillion. What explains the Dirt of Women in Top Leadership positions? Is it bias, a lack of role models, the old boys club? Sure, but it goes deeper than that. Women are trapped in a catch-22, a paradox so deeply embedded in our culture that there are few means of escape. And so it is really that very, very fine line between being a shrew on the one hand and a puppet on the other that any woman in public life has to walk. The puppet, the shrew, and the double-bind facing women who want to lead this week on Hidden Brain.
全都是男性的概率大约是36万亿分之一。如何解释高层领导中女性的匮乏？是因为偏见、缺乏榜样，还是老男孩俱乐部？当然，但事情远比这更深远。女性陷入了双重约束之中——一种深深植根于我们文化中的悖论，几乎没有逃脱的途径。因此，对于任何在公众生活中活跃的女性来说，一方面当泼妇，另一方面当傀儡，这两者之间确实只有一条非常非常细的界限。傀儡、泼妇，以及想要领导的女性所面临的双重约束，本周《隐藏的大脑》为您揭晓。
A few years ago, one of our listeners decided to switch careers. So, my name is Deborah Metta, and I am a second year marketing student in an MBA program. Deborah had been a successful teacher, but the business world appealed to her. She thought she would be a good fit. So did the program to which she applied. She was awarded a full scholarship. Soon, she was sharing the good news with an old friend. We met for coffee one day and she is very nice.
几年前，我们的听众之一决定转换职业。所以，我叫黛博拉·梅塔，是一名MBA项目的二年级市场营销专业学生。黛博拉曾是一名成功的老师，但商业世界吸引了她。她认为自己很适合。她申请的项目也是这么认为的。她被授予了全额奖学金。不久，她就把这个好消息分享给了一位老朋友。有一天我们见面喝咖啡，她非常好。
I'm still really good friends with her, but she said to me, I really can't see you in business. I think you're, you know, too sweet for the business world. It was the beginning of a series of comments that undermined her belief that she could be a leader or a manager. Later that year, Deborah's voice was the problem, specifically her habit of ending sentences on a higher pitch. A professor during a class mentioned that I do that, that I raise my, you know,
我和她仍然是非常好的朋友，但她对我说，我真的无法想象你从商。我觉得你，你知道的，对商业世界来说太温柔了。这是一系列言论的开始，这些言论动摇了她对自己能成为领导者或管理者的信念。那年晚些时候，黛博拉的声音成了问题，特别是她习惯在句子结尾时提高音调。上课时，一位教授提到我有这种习惯，就是我在句尾会提高，你知道的，
pitch at the end of a sentence. The implication was that Deborah sounded like a lightweight, not manager material. Deborah said she wasn't prepared for the offhand remarks. I mean, it really was leading me to lose confidence, the criticism of my voice, and then, you know, everyone, not everyone, but several people telling me, I'm too sweet for business. I think it really affected me. This is one side of the Catch-22.
音调。这其中的暗示是，黛博拉听起来像个无足轻重的人，不是管理者的料。黛博拉说她对这些随意的评论毫无准备。我的意思是，这真的让我失去信心，对我声音的批评，然后，你知道的，每个人——也不是每个人，但有几个人——对我说，我对商业来说太温柔了。我想这真的对我有影响。这是双重约束的一面。
Women like Deborah are seen as not tough enough to be leaders. Another listener, Tully Winston, made a different set of choices. As a manager at a construction company, a female leader in a man's world, she decided to be strategic. From the way she dresses... I've definitely chosen to go a more masculine path wearing Oxford shoes and button-downs, a straight pulled back hair and pants. To the way she greets clients, you just go in there and grab that hand and squeeze it
像黛博拉这样的女性被认为不够坚强，无法成为领导者。另一位听众图莉·温斯顿做出了一套不同的选择。作为一家建筑公司的经理，一个男人世界里的女性领导者，她决定采取战略性做法。从她的着装方式……我绝对选择了一条更具男性化风格的道路，穿着牛津鞋和系扣衬衫，梳着笔直向后的头发，穿着裤子。到她迎接客户的方式，你只要走过去握住那只手用力一捏，
because you have muscles too. I think that tends to help them go, oh wow, this is not just a lady. Tully doesn't want to appear soft or overly feminine because she knows that would be seen as weakness. But appearing tough turns out to create its own set of problems. It's definitely a double-edged sword because if I'm outspoken, all of a sudden,
因为你也有肌肉。我认为这往往有助于他们感叹，哦哇，这不仅仅是一位女士。图莉不想显得柔弱或过于女性化，因为她知道这会被视为软弱。但表现得强硬结果却带来了它自己的一系列问题。这绝对是一把双刃剑，因为如果我直言不讳，突然之间，
the men in the office will joke about, oh, whoa, whoa, watch out for Ty, watch out, she's dangerous that one. Dangerous, not driven, not strong, dangerous. We tell you their stories because together, Tuley and Debra's experiences reveal a powerful phenomenon that plays out when women strive to become leaders. The problem doesn't end with getting to the corner office, women confront the same issues when it comes to exercising power. It's a double-bind.
办公室里的男人们就会开玩笑说，哦，哇，哇，小心蒂伊，小心点，那家伙很危险。危险，不是有干劲，不是坚强，而是危险。我们给你们讲述他们的故事，因为图莉和黛博拉的经历共同揭示了一个强有力的现象：当女性努力成为领导者时，这个现象就会上演。问题并没有随着进入核心办公室而结束，女性在行使权力时也会面临同样的问题。这是一个双重约束。
Social psychologist Alice Eglie says the double-bind comes about because of a series of unconscious, interlocking stereotypes we have about men, women, and the nature of leadership. The female gender role is based on the stereotype that women are nice and kind and compassionate, but it's also expected. So people expect women to be kind of diced friendly. And smile. Now, Sazalis, consider our cultural stereotype about leaders.
社会心理学家爱丽丝·埃格利表示，双重约束的产生是因为我们对男性、女性以及领导力本质有一系列无意识的、交织在一起的刻板印象。女性性别角色基于这样一种刻板印象：女性是善良、亲切和富有同情心的，这也是人们所期望的。因此，人们期望女性表现得既亲切又友善。还要微笑。现在，埃格利说，想想我们对领导者的文化刻板印象。
In a leadership role, what is expected to take charge? And sometimes, at least to demonstrate toughness, make tough decisions, be very assertive in bringing an organization forward, sometimes fire people for cause, etc. So what's a woman to do? Be nice and kind and friendly as our gender stereotypes about women require, or be tough and decisive as our stereotypes about leadership demand. To be one is to be seen as nice, but weak. To be the other is to be seen as competent, but unlikeable. The double-bind exists for women like Tuley and Debra in the business world, but it also
在一个领导岗位上，人们期望什么？负责任。有时，至少要表现出坚强，做出艰难的决定，在推动组织前进时非常果断，有时甚至会因为正当理由解雇员工，等等。那么女性该怎么办呢？按照我们对女性的性别刻板印象要求的那样善良、亲切和友好，还是按照我们对领导力的刻板印象要求的那样坚强和果断。成为前者，就被视为善良但软弱；成为后者，就被视为有能力但不可爱。双重约束不仅存在于商业世界的图莉和黛博拉这样的女性身上，也
exists in public life, even for women with enormous power and experience. We talked to two women elected to high office. One is a Democrat, the other is a Republican. Their stories have many similarities. By the way, you may notice we refer to our guests by their first names. Their agenda biases in the way the media use names. Journalists regularly refer to women by their first names and men by their last names. On this podcast, in the interest of being conversational, we use first names for all guests.
存在于公众生活中，甚至对那些拥有巨大权力和经验的女性来说也是如此。我们采访了两位当选高级公职的女性。一位是民主党人，另一位是共和党人。她们的故事有许多相似之处。顺便说一句，你可能会注意到我们用名字来称呼我们的嘉宾。媒体在名字的使用上存在性别偏见。记者通常用名来称呼女性，而用姓来称呼男性。在这个播客中，为了保持对话的自然，我们对所有嘉宾都直呼其名。
When Carol Mosley-Bron was elected to the US Senate, she achieved a powerful first. She was the first female African-American senator. Carol says growing up, her parents shielded her from finding out how bias might limit her choices. My parents had never given me a notion that I was limited anyway by my race or my gender, and that I could just do whatever it was that I thought I wanted to do and could do. But when she got into politics, Carol realized that race and gender did matter. Of the two, she thought that racism would be the bigger barrier.
当卡罗尔·莫斯利-布朗当选美国参议员时，她取得了一个强有力的“第一”。她是第一位非洲裔美国女性参议员。卡罗尔说，在成长过程中，父母保护她免受偏见可能对其选择造成的限制。我的父母从来没有给我灌输过这样的观念：我在任何方面受到种族或性别的限制，我可以做任何我认为自己想做且能做的事。但当她进入政界后，卡罗尔意识到种族和性别确实很重要。在这两者中，她曾认为种族主义会是更大的障碍。
And I have to tell you that I think in some regards, the gender biases are more profound and more central to our culture than even the racial ones. And that, for me, was the surprise. I was expecting some pushback based on race and or gender. What I wasn't expecting was that the gender pushback would be as pronounced as it was, even more so than the racial ones. But shortly after Carol won her race, she says she confronted a second trap, the other side of the double bind.
我必须告诉你们，我认为在某些方面，性别偏见比种族偏见更深刻、更核心于我们的文化。对我和而言，这才是令人惊奇的地方。我曾预计会遇到一些基于种族和/或性别的阻力。我没有料到的是，性别阻力会如此明显，甚至比种族阻力还要大。但卡罗尔赢得竞选后不久，她说她面临着第二个陷阱——双重约束的另一面。
One time she made an impassioned plea on the floor of the Senate, but she felt her colleagues were just tuning her out. All they could hear was a stril black woman. Just because it hasn't worked and I submit to you, Mr. President, that it had came home that night. I was so upset and demeaning to use the word that I thought, okay, that's it, I can't take this anymore, I'm gonna quit. She didn't quit, but Carol still vividly recalls
有一次，她在参议院发言时做了慷慨激昂的陈述，但她觉得同事们根本不听她说话。他们听到的只是一个尖酸刻薄的黑人女性。仅仅因为它没有起作用，我向总统先生呈报，那晚它真的发生了。我感到非常不安，用这个词来贬低自己，以至于我想，好吧，就这样了，我再也受不了了，我要辞职。她没有辞职，但卡罗尔依然清晰地记得
how unfair it felt. And it wasn't just over how she was being treated, she saw her experience in the long light of history. In the 15th century, women who talked back, they would put weights on their tongue and make them walk around the square. That's a shrews punishment. The idea being that you're not supposed to have opinions about things outside of the home. And so that's a real danger for any woman in public life.
这种感觉是多么不公平。这不仅关乎她所受到的对待，她还从历史的长河中看到了自己的经历。在15世纪，顶嘴的女性会被在舌头上挂上重物，迫使她们在广场上游行。那是对泼妇的惩罚。其核心思想是，你不应该对家庭以外的事情有看法。因此，对于公众生活中的任何女性来说，这都是真正的危险。
So every stranger gets to comment on how they, what they think about you and what they think about what you just said. And if you said too much, that becomes a danger. If you said too little, that's a danger also. And so it is really that very, very fine line between being a shrew on the one hand and a puppet on the other that any lost re-election in 1998. There is a sense that a woman has to be gracious and civil and smart and smile. This is Connie Morella.
所以，每一个陌生人都可以对她们如何看待你、对你以及对你刚才所说的话发表看法。如果你说得太多，那就成了一种危险。如果你说得太少，那也是一种危险。因此，对于任何在2年落选连任的女性来说，这确实是介于一端是泼妇、另一端是傀儡之间非常非常细微的界限。人们有一种感觉，女性必须优雅、温和、聪明且面带微笑。这是康妮·莫雷拉。
Connie served for 16 years as a Republican Congresswoman from Maryland. But she's got to be strong also and indicate that she's going to persevere. Like Democrat Carol Mosley-Bron, Connie says at times she struggled to be heard. In a committee room when I was in chair of the committee, I would respond to a question or a comment on an issue. And I would say, well, thank you, Connie. That's great. And then a little later, Representative Smith said the very same thing I did. And it was, oh, Congressman Smith, that was fabulous. Let the record show that you have accomplished that or whatever. And I think, gee, I just said that. Connie Morella, Carol Mosley-Bron,
康妮作为来自马里兰州的共和党女国会议员服务了16年。但她也必须坚强，并表现出她会坚持到底。就像民主党人卡罗尔·莫斯利-布朗一样，康妮说有时她很难被听到。在一个委员会会议室里，当我担任委员会主席时，我对一个问题或评论做出回应。我会说，嗯，谢谢你，康妮。那很好。然后过了一会儿，史密斯众议员说了跟我完全相同的话。结果却是，哦，史密斯国会议员，那太棒了。请记录在案，你已经取得了这一成就，诸如此类。我想，天哪，我刚刚才说过那话。康妮·莫雷拉、卡罗尔·莫斯利-布朗、
Tully Winston, Deborah Metta, all these women feel they've experienced bias. But here's the thing, how do we know, scientifically, that they're right? Carol Mosley-Bron's Senate colleagues may have felt that perception of her was accurate. The newspaper cartoonist may have felt she really was easily manipulated. In fact, Carol herself, in her interview with us, listed numerous misstep sheet made as a
图莉·温斯顿、黛博拉·梅塔，所有这些女性都觉得她们经历过偏见。但问题是，我们如何从科学上知道她们是对的？卡罗尔·莫斯利-布朗的参议院同事可能觉得对她的看法是准确的。报纸漫画家可能觉得她确实很容易被操纵。事实上，卡罗尔本人在接受我们的采访时，也列举了她在
campaigner and as a senator. How can we tell with scientific certainty where the Carol was the victim of bias? When we look at a woman leader who appears incompetent or shrill, how do we know if we are seeing reality or just seeing the world through the lens of our own unconscious biases? This is where laboratory experiments are essential. They allow us to see precisely what's happening. We keep everything identical. We expose people to the various, what we call,
竞选和担任参议员期间犯下的无数失误。我们如何以科学的确定性来判断卡罗尔是否是偏见的受害者？当我们看到一个显得无能或尖酸刻薄的女性领导者时，我们怎么知道我们看到的是现实，还是仅仅通过我们自己无意识偏见的镜头在看世界？这就是实验室实验必不可少的原因。它们让我们能够准确地看到发生了什么。我们保持一切完全相同。我们让人们接触各种我们称之为
experimental conditions. And at the end of the day, if we find a difference, we can say that it has to be due to that thing that we were studying. And that's the nature of a controlled experiment. Stay with us. When we judge a person's character, we usually think our opinions are based on fact. What we forget is that the world that enters our brain has been filtered.
实验条件的东西。到头来，如果我们发现差异，我们就可以说这一定是由我们正在研究的那件事引起的。这就是对照实验的本质。请继续收听。当我们判断一个人的性格时，我们通常认为我们的意见是基于事实的。我们忘记的是，进入我们大脑的世界已经被过滤了。
Figuring out what those filters are and how they distort our vision has long intrigued Madeline Hylman. She's a psychology professor at New York University who focuses on gender stereotypes and bias, particularly when it comes to leadership. What we have found consistently is that when we present women and men with exactly the same credentials, qualifications, and backgrounds, for a job that is traditionally male, held by men in our culture, thought to require male attributes,
弄清楚这些过滤器是什么以及它们如何扭曲我们的视野，长期以来一直吸引着玛德琳·海尔曼。她是纽约大学的心理学教授，专注于性别刻板印象和偏见，特别是在领导力方面。我们一直发现的是，当我们为一项传统上属于男性、在我们文化中由男性担任、被认为需要男性特质的工作向女性和男性提供完全相同的资历、资格和背景时，
we consistently find that the woman is seen as more incompetent than the man. The problem doesn't end there. Sometimes women really do show their competence and it's unavoidable and we can't, we can't deny it. And what happens then? Well the research that I've done has shown that when women are truly successful in areas where they're not expected to be, there's a very negative reaction, there's disapproval, and they are penalized, they're disliked, but they're also seen as really
我们总是发现女性被认为比男性更无能。问题并未就此结束。有时女性确实表现出了她们的能力，这是不可避免的，我们不能、也无法否认。那接下来会发生什么呢？嗯，我做过的前期研究表明，当女性在她们不被看好的领域真正取得成功时，会出现非常负面的反应，会有不赞同，她们会受到惩罚，不被人喜欢，而且她们还会被看作是
almost really awful depictions of what kinds of people they are, words like bitter and choral sum, selfish and deceitful and devious and manipulative and cold. These are words that are attributed to these women who are successful where they are not supposed to be, and I should put that in quotes. They have terms for these people, you know, ice queen and dragon lady and iron maiden and so on and so forth. I want to emphasize, these aren't Madeline's opinions. They are the findings of her experiments.
对她们是怎样的人的非常糟糕的描绘，诸如痛苦、好争吵、自私、欺骗、阴险、狡猾和冷酷之类的词。这些词被用来形容那些在她们不该成功的地方取得成功的女性，我应该把这几个字加上引号。人们对这些人有各种称呼，你知道的，冰女王、龙夫人、铁娘子等等。我想强调的是，这些不是玛德琳的个人观点。它们是她实验的结果。
In one study, Madeline asked volunteers to evaluate a high-powered manager joining a company. Sometimes volunteers are told the manager is a man, other times they're told it's a woman. When the person was presented as a very high-power person who was very ambitious. We found that the person was seen as much more unlikable when it was a woman than when it was a man. To be clear, the high-powered male and female manager are described in identical terms down to the letter.
在一项研究中，玛德琳请志愿者评估一位加入公司的强势经理。有时志愿者被告知这位经理是男性，有时则被告知是女性。当把这个人表现为一个非常有权势、非常有野心的人时。我们发现，当这个人是女性时，比是男性时更不讨人喜欢。需要澄清的是，高权力的男性和女性经理的描述在字面上是完全相同的。
The only thing different is that one is said to be a man and the other is said to be a woman. Madeline has also looked at what happens when someone joins a company but is not said to be in a position of power. If we didn't give information about how successful the person was, just had them applying for a job, we find that the women are as likable as the man, but their scene is less competent. And that is the rock in the hard place, the double-bine, that if it's not clear that you're successful, and you have the same information about a woman and a man,
唯一的区别是一个被称为男性，另一个被称为女性。玛德琳还研究了当有人加入公司但并未处于权力的位置时会发生什么。如果我们不提供关于这个人有多成功的信息，只是让他们申请工作，我们发现女性和男性一样讨人喜欢，但她们被认为能力较差。这就是左右为难的困境，也就是双重约束：如果并不清楚你是否成功，而你又拥有关于女性和男性的相同信息，
the woman has seen is less competent. If you have very clear indication that there is success, then the woman is rated as unlikeable. They see her as competent but unlikeable. Madeline says the double binderizes because our minds are trying to align our stereotypes about men and women with our stereotypes about leadership. We have conceptions of these jobs and these positions
女性就会被认为能力较差。如果你有非常明确的成功迹象，那么女性就会被评为不受欢迎。人们认为她有能力但不可爱。玛德琳说，双重约束的出现是因为我们的大脑试图将我们对男性和女性的刻板印象与我们对领导力的刻板印象结合起来。我们对这些工作和职位有概念，
and what is required to do them well. And there's a lack of fit between how we see women and what these positions require. The biases Madeline describes aren't just held by men. They're held by both sexes, which explains why many female leaders encountered derision and suspicion from both men and women. I think that this comes from the social roles that people have played over time. Women stayed home and they took care, men went out and they took charge of things. That is the kind of origin, I think, of the stereotypes
以及做好这些工作需要什么。我们如何看待女性与这些职位所要求的内容之间存在不匹配。玛德琳所描述的偏见不仅存在于男性之中。男女双方都存在这种偏见，这就解释了为什么许多女性领导者会遭遇来自男女双方的嘲笑和怀疑。我认为这源于人们随时间推移所扮演的社会角色。女性留在家中照顾家庭，男性外出掌管事务。我认为，这就是我们所持有的
that we hold. We have very strong feelings about how men and women are, and that leads to the idea that women are less competent than men in a lot of these fields that we're talking about. And we have real strong ideas about how they should be, and that leads to this dislike when they go over the line, when they tread where they're not supposed to be. There are other aspects to the double-bind. Female leaders can get in trouble for displaying emotion, but also for not displaying emotion. Lisa Feldman-Barritt is a psychology professor at Northeastern University and author of the book, How Emotions Are Made.
刻板印象的起源。我们对男性的表现和女性的表现有非常强烈的感觉，这导致了这样一种观点：在我们正在讨论的很多领域中，女性不如男性有能力。我们对她们应该是什么样有着非常强烈的看法，当她们越界、涉足不该涉足的领域时，就会导致这种反感。双重约束还有其他方面。女性领导者可能会因为表现出情绪而陷入麻烦，也会因为不表现出情绪而陷入麻烦。莉萨·费尔德曼-巴雷特是东北大学的心理学教授，也是《情绪是如何产生的》一书的作者。
There is an implication that if a woman expresses emotion that she's either unsuitable for leadership or unstable in some way, or if she doesn't express enough emotion, she's also seen rather than being seen as rational and kind of level-headed, she's seen as, you know, not empathic, not warm, and generally not trustworthy. In one experiment, Lisa showed volunteers pictures of faces and asked why the subject was expressing an emotion. She found that the volunteers thought men's emotions were shaped by what was going on
有一种暗示是，如果一个女性表达情绪，要么说明她不适合担任领导职务，要么说明她在某种程度上不稳定；或者如果她没有表达足够的情绪，她也不会被视为理性、冷静，而是被认为，你知道的，缺乏同理心、不够温暖，通常不值得信任。在一个实验中，莉萨向志愿者展示了面部照片，并询问为什么照片中的人会表达某种情绪。她发现志愿者认为男性的情绪是由他们周围发生的事情塑造的，
around them, but that women's emotions were shaped by their nature. Both men and women, when they were looking at female faces expressing emotion, believed that this was caused by a woman's emotional nature. She's just a neurotic person. She's just unstable. She's just untrustworthy, as opposed to when they were looking at male faces expressing emotion, they were more likely to say, oh, he's just having a bad day. Something bad happened to him. just having a bad day, something bad happened to him. Lots of people have suggested ways out of the double-bind. Some say women should ignore criticisms about incompetence and plunge full steam ahead. If they then appear unlikable, they should also go out of their way to demonstrate kindness in order to keep people from seeing
而女性的情绪则是由她们的本性决定的。无论男女，当他们看着表达情绪的女性面孔时，都认为这是由女性的情感本性引起的。她只是个神经质的人。她只是不稳定。她只是不值得信任，而当他们看着表达情绪的男性面孔时，他们更有可能会说，哦，他只是今天过得不顺。他发生了一些不好的事情。只是今天过得不顺，他发生了一些不好的事情。许多人都提出了摆脱双重约束的方法。有人说女性应该忽略对无能的批评，全速前进。如果她们因此显得不可爱，她们也应该竭尽全力表现出善良，以免人们认为
them as competent but cold. There is something disturbing about these ideas. They ask women who are the victims here to compensate for the biases of others. Many experts also think that a society changes our stereotypes will change as well. If more women make it through the labyrinth and get to the top, fewer people will have trouble seeing women as leaders. Many countries and organizations are coming to think of leadership as being collaborative rather than dictatorial. The less we think of leaders as alpha males, the easier it's going to be for our unconscious minds to see women as leaders. If there's one common thread here, it's that ending the double bind can't be just on the women reaching for high office or the corner office. It has to be on all of us.
她们有能力但冷酷。这些想法有些令人不安。它们要求作为受害者的女性去补偿他人的偏见。许多专家还认为，随着社会的发展，我们的刻板印象也会改变。如果有更多的女性穿过迷宫登上顶峰，就会有更少的人难以将女性视为领导者。许多国家和组织开始将领导力视为协作式而非独裁式的。我们越少把领导者视为阿尔法男性，我们的潜意识就越容易将女性视为领导者。如果这里有一个共同的线索，那就是结束双重约束不能仅仅依靠追求高级公职或核心办公室的女性。这必须靠我们所有人。
This week's episode was produced by Jenny Schmidt and edited by Tara Boyle. A staff includes Parts Shaw, Raina Cohen, Match Watts and Rene Clarre. If you like this episode, I'm going to ask you to tell two friends, one man and one woman about our show. Our unsung hero this week is Anja Grunman. She's the person who oversees NPR's podcast. She's always had our back and there's a reason her calendar is always maxed out. Anja is the very definition of that collaborative leader we were just talking about. She makes everyone around her better.
本期节目由珍妮·施密特制作，塔拉·博伊尔编辑。工作人员包括帕茨·肖、雷娜·科恩、马奇·瓦茨和雷妮·克拉尔。如果你喜欢这期节目，我要请你向两位朋友——一男一女——推荐我们的节目。我们本周的无名英雄是安娅·格伦曼。她是监督NPR播客的人。她总是支持我们，她的日程总是排得满满的，这是有原因的。安娅正是我们刚才讨论的那种协作型领导者的定义。她让周围的每个人都变得更好。
You can find more hidden brain on Facebook and Twitter and listen for my stories on your local public radio station. I'm Shankar Vitantum and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Facebook和Twitter上找到更多《隐藏的大脑》的内容，并收听你在当地公共广播电台播出的我的故事。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。本集节目尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。